[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Hello, and welcome
to the seventh episode of the
weekly Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy and I'm here
with my co-host, Mark Mandel.
Hi, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hi, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Pretty good.
Very happy to be
here in San Francisco
recording in this
beautiful voiceover room.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's great.
At least the weather's
nice here in San Francisco.
Raining, but it's pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Ready for the weekend.
What are we going to be
talking about today, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: Today we're going
to talk about Cloud Messaging.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Ooh.
Interesting.
MARK MANDEL: It's actually--
I quite like this topic.
I think it's going
to be a lot of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I like
it because it's something
that people don't
really talk about.
Because it's not glamorous.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
But it's necessary.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You need it.
Yeah.
Totally.
MARK MANDEL: It is,
quite literally,
the plumbing of the internet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Oh, that's a beautiful metaphor.
MARK MANDEL: Do you like that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I like that.
MARK MANDEL: You
like that a lot?
All right.
But before we get
into that, should we
talk about our cool
thing of the week?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
The cool thing of the week-- I'm
sure that most of our listeners
actually might have
seen it already.
There is some really
cool videos going around.
It's the Google
Cloud Vision API.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds pretty exciting.
I haven't had a
chance, too much,
to sit down and look at it.
Have you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have
not really played with it.
I've read the documentation,
which is something.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I
played with something that
was built on top of the API.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Basically, if you've
heard before about
TensorFlow-- which is something
that we released not that
long ago-- which is basically
revolutionizing how machine
learning can be done,
like deep learning, neural
networks, and so on.
Google has done a lot of
that for quite a long time.
We open sourced the way we do
that, which is a great thing.
It's called TensorFlow.
And even though it's
really powerful,
it's also quite
complicated to use.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
the Google Cloud Vision
API does-- it just packages
some models-- sometime
TensorFlow models--
that are already
trained to recognize
things in pictures,
which are, pretty much, what
we use for Google Photos.
MARK MANDEL: So I could
send it a picture of my dog
and it would be like,
oh, that's a dog.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's a dog.
Yeah, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's basically
what we use for Google Photos.
It's exactly the same.
So you can send the picture
and ask, what is this?
And you're going to get a
bunch of labels and information
about it.
So it will be able to say,
oh, yeah, that's a dog.
But also, it could
say something--
that's a dog next to a
cat and things like that.
So it's actually really smart.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
OK.
So I could do things like
facial detection and be like,
which person is that?
I could be like,
what logo is it?
And do some OCR type stuff--
so character recognition.
That sounds like a
really powerful thing.
And basically, I can just
plug and play with it.
So I don't have to--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: I don't have to
know how this machine learning
stuff works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
the great thing about it.
It's basically
just one more API.
The same way you
use the data store,
you can use now
this service that
allows you to discover
what's in a picture.
So that's great.
MARK MANDEL: Brilliant.
I'm having a look here.
It looks like if
people want to join,
it's currently in
limited preview.
But there is a form
they can sign up
for if they want
to get involved.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And we will have that link
in the show notes, as usual.
MARK MANDEL: Most definitely.
All right.
That sounds pretty awesome.
I can't wait to sit down
and really play with that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And actually,
the even cooler thing
of the week-- which is the cool
thing built on top of the cool
thing of the week-- is
something that Brett Abrams,
who is a product
manager here at Google--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, he did
this really cool thing.
That's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
He did this little game,
which is really cool
because it's a game where
you get a list of words.
And then you have to
take pictures of things
that match those words.
MARK MANDEL: So it's a
digital scavenger hunt.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Basically.
MARK MANDEL: That's awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I really
loved it because you can retry.
You can get new lists.
So I got one that
was quite easy.
It was like dog and eating
and things like that.
So that was doable.
I've also seen-- and this
is actually for Brad.
Brad, if you're listening to
us, putting paranormal creature
on a list like that
is not really helpful.
It's not really fair.
MARK MANDEL: I want to
know how they have managed
to get the model to recognize
paranormal creatures
and how many ghosts they had
to find to get that to happen.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
I thought that was
very interesting.
It's like, go take a picture
of a paranormal creature.
I was like, mmm, no.
MARK MANDEL: As like,
somebody putting Loch Ness
on the scavenger list.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's a good thing to have.
MARK MANDEL: Bigfoot, a
yeti-- all that sort of stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But, yeah,
we'll have a link to the-- it's
a small Android app, so
you can give it a try.
It's really fun.
And the good thing is that
the source code is actually
really simple.
It's basically just
a little API call.
That's pretty much it.
So it's great.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
I like that.
I like that a lot.
That's really sweet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
For our main content
today, as you were saying,
we're going to be talking about
messaging and the plumbing
of thew internet.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
This is something a little
bit near and dear to my heart.
I quite like it.
We want to talk about-- how
do we want to set the stage?
Generally, this sort
of stuff comes up
when you want to do either
asynchronous processing,
or maybe you have
disparate systems
that want to be able to
communicate with each other
through some sort
of messaging system.
What options are available
on Google Cloud Platform
to let you do that?
And why would you
choose one over another?
And I think-- to set the stage--
I think, really, we're looking
at two particular pieces.
One of which is Task queues,
which have been around
for a long time.
They've been in App Engine.
And something that's relatively
newer-ish, or at least
relatively newer
released publicly,
is Cloud Pub/Sub, which
is pretty exciting.
So I think we'll end up
talking about both of those.
Have you worked with those?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've definitely
used Task queues before.
Task Queues have been
around for a very long time.
So I've used it for many
demos that I've done.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And it's
really simple to use.
It's beautiful.
It's very well integrated
with App Engine.
So if you're doing
App Engine, it's
probably the way to go with it.
And then I also used
Pub/Sub up in my last demo.
The Google Cloud
Spin uses Pub/Sub
to communicate to send tasks
across all the workers.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Why don't we explain
what both of them
are and we can
continue on from there?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Since I've used
Task queues more--
MARK MANDEL: Go for it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --I will
explain what Task queues is.
Basically, Task queues are just
a very basic implementation.
And by basic, I mean very simple
to use and very down to earth.
It's nothing really fancy.
Basically, what you can
do is you have queues.
And these queues-- you
can think about them
like pipes-- like Linux pipes.
Or just a first in, first
out thing on the Cloud,
where you can send messages
on one side and then,
on the other side,
you can receive them.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And you
have two ways of doing that.
Sending those messages can
be done through a REST API
or directly from App
Engine, you have some--
MARK MANDEL: You
have a nice client.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You have a very nice client
that you can use very easily.
And then, on the other side,
the way you receive them-- you
have two choices.
One is what we call a pool task.
And a pool task is basically
when you are asking-- OK, I'm
ready to receive a task.
Give me one task.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And once
you're done traiting that task,
you send out a message, which
is an acknowledgement, saying,
hey, I'm done with that task.
You can delete it.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
actually really powerful.
Because that way,
if for some reason--
you start traiting that
task-- and for some reason,
the machine just crashes,
you don't lose that task.
MARK MANDEL: It can still retry.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It will be retried later
on, after some time out time
that we have.
So that's very simple and
it's very often what you want.
You can also have something
which is the opposite way.
Rather than the workers
asking for a new task,
is actually the task being
sent directly to the workers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
that works really well
if you have, for
instance, something
like some kind of load balancer
and a bunch of machines behind.
MARK MANDEL: Especially
like App Engine.
If you're using App Engine,
that works perfectly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On App
Engine, it works really well.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But then, you still
have the fact that if you
tried to send that task
and you respond to that
task with something else,
like 200 or 202--
basically, an OK
HTTP code-- then that task
will be retried later on.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
when we retry things,
there's always this
exponential back up-- back out.
MARK MANDEL: One of
the things I really
like about Task Queues is
it's a configuration file.
It's a YAML file-- much like
everything we always do--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's true.
MARK MANDEL: --that allows
you to say how quickly
and how often you want
things to get processed.
And also, you have
a lot of control
over how you want to retry--
how many times, what sort of
back off, all that stuff.
So you have a lot of
control over all the Task
Queues in every system.
And you can have more than one.
It's quite powerful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You can have as many
tasks as you want.
MARK MANDEL: And the
other thing I really
like about task queues--
with push tasks,
specifically-- you can
defer them for later.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is really nice, too.
You want to run this
in half an hour,
or you want to run this the next
day, or something like that,
but do it's as a one-off thing,
that's also quite powerful.
It's pretty nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I've seen it used very
often for two different use
cases that are very different,
but work very well with task
queues.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The first one being,
you have some list of
things that you have to do.
Imagine, for instance,
you have some forum
and you have to
moderate the new posts.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Those posts--
you can put them inside
of a task queue.
And then the web page
itself-- maybe even
JavaScript-- you can access.
Give me the next task.
You present it and then you
have everything done there.
So it's very simple to
do and it works very well
with a pool mode.
And the other one
is when you want
to do something
at it a bit later
because that way, your
request will finish faster.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So like a performance increase.
That makes a lot of sense.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
For instance, if
you have something
where you receive a request,
and as a result of that request,
you have to send an email.
Sending an email might take
some time, so you don't--
MARK MANDEL: Maybe you have
some attachments or something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Maybe you need to go find some
images or something like that.
So very often,
it's better-- what
you want to do is just
to create that task
and say that will be done as
soon as possible, but not right
now.
And then just return
a 200 to the customer.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That makes a lot of sense.
That's a lot of sense.
All right.
Cool.
So Task Queues sound
pretty powerful.
They sound like they've got a
lot of really great features.
So I guess it falls on
me to talk about Pub/Sub.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I think so, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, great.
I've worked with Pub/Sub before.
Pub/Sub is pretty
much, actually,
exactly as he explained.
If anyone's looked at the
software patent of Publish
Subscribe, it is exactly that.
You have publishers which
can send out messages.
And they send those
messages to topics.
And this is exactly what
is called inside Pub/Sub.
Those topics, essentially--
everything about Pub/Sub
is HTTP, which I think is great.
Makes things really simple.
It's actually specifically
over HTTPS, so it's secure.
Publishers can push messages
to JSON packets straight
to topics that can be created.
Any number of
publishers, that is.
And then, any number
of subscribers
can subscribe to those topics
and get those messages.
So you can do fan in, fan out,
so many to one, one to many--
all that good stuff.
So you can build some really
nice, decoupled architecture.
Pretty much like what you can
do with which Task Queues,
but you have this
opportunity here where
you can have many people
listening, or many subscribers
listening, to a
single message, which
you can't do with Task Queues.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very nice.
Basically, with Pub/Sub,
you're able to do broadcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And you
cannot really do that with Task
Queues.
That's true.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It gives you a little bit
more flexibility that way.
The really cool
thing about this--
while it is relatively new,
as well, it's pretty battle
tested.
I actually started
using it way back
when, when it first came
out and it was really new,
but it was rock solid.
Basically, it's because
it's the same thing
that powers things like ads
and Hangouts within the site
Google.
And you know anything
that powers ads inside
Google-- that has to work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That has
the work of all the time.
MARK MANDEL: All the time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And very fast.
Much like Task Queues,
it's guaranteed
to be at least once to show up.
So it's persistent storage.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
actually very important.
It will not happen
very often that you
receive the same task twice.
MARK MANDEL: I don't
think I've ever seen it,
but it could happen.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
have never seen it,
but you should be ready
for that happening.
So it's important to be able to
treat a second request as just
not important.
You can either ignore it or
you do the treatment twice.
But that doesn't take
you into a wrong state.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Make sure it's [INAUDIBLE].
Make sure it--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
That's the word-- [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: That's
super important.
It's also worth noting,
as well, Pub/Sub-- also,
again, like you can
with Task Queues--
there's a lot of
similarities here.
You can do both push and pull,
very much like Task Queues.
So you might use
push when you want
to send it directly to somebody
who needs to receive it.
It fires an HTTP request
with the data straight in it.
But then, also, you can
do pull requests, as well.
So you can say, I want to
grab the last 10 or 15.
What's the max number?
And it sends it down.
That can be quite
useful if you don't
want to be order
scaling all the time.
You want to say, I've
got three machines
and I just want
to keep it going.
But the nice thing is
that it has integration
with cloud monitoring.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: So if you want
to do some auto scaling based
on how much stuff is
in your Pub/Sub queue--
or in your Pub/Sub topic, I
should say-- you can do that.
And that integration
is quite nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And that's something that you
cannot do out of the box with
Task Queues.
It's something that,
maybe, you could implement,
but it's definitely not as
simple to do as with Pub/Sub.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
But the other flipside
is Task Queues
give you all the
knobs to play with.
To say, I want to go faster
here or back off more there.
Whereas Pub/Sub is
more rudimentary.
It has that retry mechanisms.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: But it's just
like, this is the way it works.
It doesn't-- you
don't have like, oh,
I want it to back off once
and then go back 10 seconds,
then 15, then 20.
You It's like you're on
Pub/Sub's dime on how
that works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's where
the task queues give you
more fine grained tuning.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
there's things that
are actually quite interesting.
For instance, you can
actually have throttling.
You could say, oh, in this
task-- only for push tasks,
though.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Because if you do pull--
MARK MANDEL: Pull,
it doesn't matter.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: As soon as
you pull, you got new tasks.
But when you push tasks,
you could say, oh,
yeah I don't want to send more
than 10 messages per second.
And this can be really powerful,
because if you have a traffic
peak, your task queue will
just moderate that traffic peak
and just keep the tasks
for a little bit later.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So your users
will experience some lag,
but your system will continue
working with that [INAUDIBLE]
glitch.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Whereas with Pub/Sub, if
you wanted to do that,
you'd have to do
it as a pull queue.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: You'd have
to regulate it yourself
and say this is how often I want
to be processing each message.
The other thing with
Pub/Sub-- regardless
of whether you do
push or pull, you
have to send back
an ACK message.
You have to acknowledge
that you're done.
That's really important.
And it's a bit simpler that way.
I don't know-- maybe in my mind.
Regardless of whether you
push or pull, as long as you--
once you're done, you have to
say, hey, I'm done with it.
You specify deadline with it.
So you're like,
this is how long I
think it's going to take
when you set up everything.
But then, once you say
ACK, it's like, oh, cool.
I'll delete it now.
I'm good to go.
Otherwise, yeah, then you
get into that retry mechanism
and everything works from there.
But yeah.
I mean, one thing I
really love about Pub/Sub
is that it doesn't require
any special type of transport
layer.
You don't need any
like custom clients,
you don't need to be talking
over special sockets,
or anything like that.
It's all HTTP.
It's all JSON packets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's all,
pretty much, plain text
going over the wire.
So anything that can talk that,
which is pretty much anything,
that's great.
And so then you can
do inner communication
between whatever you like.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And
it's really flexible
and you never-- if you
want to add something
extra-- for example-- what's the
great example I'm thinking of?
You want to do something
Task Queue-ish, for example.
You were talking about--
say you were doing-- I want
to process this image later.
You could put that
into a Pub/Sub topic,
much like you could
with task queues.
But then, maybe later
on, you're like, oh,
what I also want to
do is I want to log
every time I do that, as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So then
you go, OK, that's fine.
I will just add
another subscription
to my Pub/Sub thing.
Same thing.
Don't have to change
any of my other code.
And then I'm like, oh, I've
just got another listener
to this particular topic
when the image comes in
and then I'll log it.
And then maybe you're
like, oh, actually,
I also want to do this
other thing with an image.
And you can continue
on from there.
And that's a really
powerful medium, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's really nice.
The fact that you
can basically have
a much generic architecture,
where you can add
stuff without
modifying any code.
That's really powerful.
MARK MANDEL: That's
super, super powerful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What you
were saying about-- yeah,
there's no specific transport
that is required or anything.
Just like HTTP, after
HTTPS with JSON.
That's actually also the
case for Task Queues.
MARK MANDEL: That is true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah.
Don't get too excited.
MARK MANDEL: I feel like we're
having this battle here your
on Task Queue's side and
I'm on Pub/Sub's side.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I actually
like Pub/Sub a lot, too.
But there's also something
really important,
which we have not
mentioned, which
is there is absolutely
nothing that you
need to do to get Pub/Sub
or Task Queues working.
You don't need to
install anything.
MARK MANDEL: No, that's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You don't
need to manage anything.
It's fully managed services
that are a part of Google Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
If you need to use them,
you just start using them.
That's it.
MARK MANDEL: That's it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There's nothing to do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That's a really good point.
Why don't we go through some
of the feature comparisons
between the two, so people
get a bit of an idea of maybe
which bits they
might want to use
in their application for what?
Because there is a
lot of overlap there.
We're going to put this
table up in the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL:
Francesc is nodding.
He agrees with me.
Good.
So yeah.
We can-- you can
dig into it further.
But I think it's
worth going into.
Because there is overlap.
I can see why people
would be like,
oh, I'm going to go
this way or go that way.
I can think of what my
rule of thumb might be.
Maybe it's different
from your rule of thumb.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You'll have to say it
so I can agree or disagree.
MARK MANDEL: I probably lean
more towards Pub/Sub these days
than task queues.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Just
because it allows
you more flexibility to
add extra things to it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: But I
do put some caveats
on that, in terms
of if you do need
that fine grained control over
processing speed or retries,
could go task queues.
You could also just do
pull requests on Pub/Sub.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
For me, it's a
little bit different.
For me, it depends
on what I'm doing.
If I'm building
an App Engine app,
task queues is very
well integrated with it.
MARK MANDEL: That is true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I will
probably go with Task Queues.
If I'm not using Task-- if I'm
not using App Engine-- if I'm
doing something on Compute
Engine, which is my own code,
especially if it's involving
something which is not
a part of the cloud--
like internet of things--
and you have many devices
that are around, communication
with those over
Pub/Sub, that's going
to be much, much better to do.
Except for one
little thing, which
is if you need
something-- there's
something that Pub/Sub doesn't
offer that Task Queue does,
which is do this
in half an hour.
MARK MANDEL: That is true.
That is true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The fact
that-- and that can be quite--
MARK MANDEL: That's
quite powerful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Quite powerful.
You can do something
like, oh, yeah,
I'm receiving this request.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Check in
half an hour if this happened.
If it didn't happen,
do this other thing.
MARK MANDEL: I've worked it out.
You create a Task Queue that
then creates a Pub/Sub message.
Done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Aw.
Probably.
OK.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You could do that, too.
MARK MANDEL: It really depends.
Again, you probably need
simplicity, as well.
But that's fair enough.
No, that's cool.
And there's one other cute
trick that Task Queues
do that we actually--
I'll be devil's
advocate against myself.
If you're on App Engine,
you can do transactions
within Datastore that wrap
around your task queues.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
that's very powerful.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is quite cool.
So if you're like, I'm going
to put some data in Datastore,
and then I want to
create a task, basically,
against that data, you can
wrap that up in a transaction
so that they're one in the same.
So if one of them-- if it
fails, it all falls down.
You could probably
replicate it using Pub/Sub
and your own [INAUDIBLE] stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That'd
be quite hard, I guess.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You could probably do it in
some ways, like check it.
But the fact that those
are integrated quite nicely
together--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's very nice.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty cool.
It is pretty cool.
We mentioned the feature matrix
before we went off there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Yeah.
Cool.
The first feature is
you can pull and push
via-- no, pull via API.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
That works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Which is a rest API.
We also have clients,
but those are--
MARK MANDEL: They both work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Both Task Queues and Pub/Sub.
What about pushing
via web hooks?
Actually, pushing to
web hooks, basically?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
They both have that, obviously.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: They both have
that under one condition, which
is HTTPS.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which is
always-- you should always--
MARK MANDEL: You should do
that anyway, so that's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah.
What about the size of every
single message that gets sent?
MARK MANDEL: That's
an interesting one.
Task queues have a
limited 100K per message.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: Pub/Sub's a
little bit more interesting.
It's actually 10 megabytes
per published request.
But you can send up to 1,000
messages within that request.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you
could send 1,000 messages
and every single message
could have 1,000 bytes.
MARK MANDEL: Get the math right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
OK.
So you could send 1K
messages of 1K size.
MARK MANDEL:
Something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which is 1 Meg.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
I think that math sounds right.
Yeah, so you could do that.
Or you could send one message
that is up to 10 megabytes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: So you have
some flexibility there,
which is pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
important to tell
that-- to say that even though
you can send 10 Megs, Pub/Sub
and Task Queues-- in general,
messaging systems are not
really built to handle
really big size of files.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You probably should
store big data
somewhere persistent, like
storage or Datastore or Cloud
SQL.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And [INAUDIBLE] is
the path to that.
Or something like that.
It's much better than just
sending big files inside.
That's not a very good idea.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I agree 100%.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about
the delivery guarantee?
Am I sure that I will
receive those messages?
MARK MANDEL: I would hope so.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And again, that's the
little difference.
You will receive that message
and probably only once.
But, maybe, you might
receive it twice.
So your actions should be
[INAUDIBLE] just in case
that arrives.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
have batch inserts--
being able to insert more than
one task or message at a time.
Can you do that?
MARK MANDEL: You can only
do that in App Engine, which
is interesting.
The REST API-- if you're
outside App Engine
and you want to
use the REST API,
you can only send
one task at a time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
being for Task Queues.
OK.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
for Task Queues.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
But on Pub/Sub, you can
do whatever you want.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So there's
no limitation there.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
you have to send it
under 10 megabytes and
up to 1,000 messages.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But you can send
as many messages
as you want, regardless of
where you're sending them from.
Can you have multiple receivers?
In a Task Queue, if you
create only one task queue,
and I send one
message, how many times
will that message be received?
MARK MANDEL: Once.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, OK.
MARK MANDEL: Just once.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just once.
That's it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But on
Pub/Sub, there's actually
not that limitation either.
Because it will be received
once per subscription.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And you can
add more subscription per topic.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Basically, you can
have-- you have a little bit of
best of both worlds, where you
can have per subscription,
it will be received
by only one of the receivers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Topics can have up to
10,000 subscriptions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Which is quite big.
MARK MANDEL: It seems
reasonable amount.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's a-- yeah.
10,000-- yeah, I don't think
I've ever done something
with that many machines.
Well, other than when
I was working for ads.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
about the maximum number
of messages per second?
MARK MANDEL: You were looking
at this for Task Queues.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Do you want to try
and explain that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So I'm going to go
first with Pub/Sub.
There's no limit.
MARK MANDEL: There's no limit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just go for it.
There's no limit on that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just
go crazy with that.
With Task Queues, there's a
limitation, which is first,
you have to activate billing.
If you have the billing
activated, that won't work.
But then you can go up to
1 billion messages per day,
which is quite big.
MARK MANDEL: Seems reasonable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And the recommendation
is you should not
go over 250 messages
per second per queue.
So you have multiple queues,
that doesn't really count.
MARK MANDEL: So you can
shard it if you need to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, you can
shard over multiple queues.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
OK.
This seems to handle, I think,
probably most people's load.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
If you have like one
billion messages per day.
I have not made the maths
to know how many messages
per second, but that's a lot.
MARK MANDEL: A lot.
I'd go with a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's go with a lot.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
go with a lot.
We were talking about
throttling before.
Yeah.
Task Queues has built in
throttling so you have control
within that YAML file.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
For push queues.
MARK MANDEL: For push queues.
Yeah.
But you always do pull
and control it yourself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Though, with
Pub/Sub, if you're going to do
throttling, you need
to do it yourself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Which is actually
not that complicated.
I've done it before.
Basically, what you do is
every single receiver--
every single worker-- it will
just sleep for two seconds
before going for the next task.
That's it.
MARK MANDEL: That's it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
that simple, really.
MARK MANDEL: Or you
could just keep it going.
If you're just happy-- I mean,
you're paying for the machine
anyway.
You've got an OVM.
You might as well
just keep churning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, there's-- yeah.
You don't need to do
anything special, really.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Now, performance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The performance--
it's quite interesting.
Because it really depends
on what you're trying to do.
I'm going to go
first with Pub/Sub.
We actually have a
link to that, which is
you will get subsecond times.
Normally, you will get
milliseconds on both-- Task
Queues and Pub/Sub.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But on Pub/Sub, you
will get even less than a
second, even when you're
sending more than one
million messages per second.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
really good, actually.
That means that it scales
really, really well.
MARK MANDEL: Well, it
powers ads and Hangouts.
I mean, it has to, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So that's the thing.
Pub/Sub will scale like crazy.
You can just go for
it and there will
be a little bit
of a degradation,
but it will never go up
over one second, which
is actually quite decent.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On
Task Queues, though,
the scalability
won't be that big.
So if you're trying to
send that many messages,
probably Pub/Sub could be a--
if you were doing big data with
a bunch-- imagine if you have
sensors in-- I don't know--
every--
MARK MANDEL: Every place ever.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Every place ever.
That's a good place
to have sensors.
And those sensors are actually
sending data all the time.
You have that much data
coming in-- probably
Pub/Sub is the way to go.
MARK MANDEL: Pub/Sub
seems to be the way to go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And finally, we'll
also mention Cloud Monitoring.
Cloud Monitoring--
as we said, Pub/Sub
allows you to have a
monitoring measure.
So you can-- the
things based on that.
Alerts and all the things,
like-- I forgot the word.
MARK MANDEL: Say if you
were wanting to throttle
or you want to do autoscale.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Autoscale, that's it.
MARK MANDEL: Or that sort of fun
stuff and see what's going on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If
you want to autoscale,
you can do that based on the
number of messages in Pub/Sub.
MARK MANDEL: I actually
like the idea, as well,
of doing alerts,
which is kind of cool.
If you hit past a certain
point, you'll be--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
can toy with that
or you can do it the
other way around.
You can say, if we're getting
less than 100 messages
per second, something's wrong.
MARK MANDEL: Something's wrong.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
just let me know.
And you can do that very easily
from the monitoring console.
MARK MANDEL: Can you do
that with Task Queues?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
could do it manually.
There's not a thing
that does that.
MARK MANDEL: Doesn't integrate.
OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
If you really want to do Task
Queues, and the only limitation
that you have is I would
like to have monitoring.
You could build
it on top of that.
There's not such a limitation.
But you have to build it.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Fair enough.
All right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Well I think
that probably covers
that topic quite succinctly.
Have you got anything
else you can think of?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not really.
I think that we've talked about
messaging enough for today.
Yeah.
But if there's anyone
that has questions about,
hey, I'm trying to do this,
is it better to do Task Queues
or Pub/Sub, let us
know what you're doing
and we're here to help you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
hello@gcppodcast.com.
Hit us up on Twitter
at GCP Podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The Reddit.
We have a Subreddit--
r/gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: And also
+GCPPodcast on Google+,
as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
Cool.
OK.
Great.
Before we go, what is the
question of the week today?
MARK MANDEL: The
question of the week.
It has to do with logging data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
More data.
MARK MANDEL: I know
what people are saying.
Look, I think it's interesting.
Logging data is the
bread and butter.
It's the core of
anything you do.
You need to know what
your application is doing.
It's super important.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's even
less glamorous the messaging,
but even more
important, probably.
MARK MANDEL: Probably.
Probably.
Google Cloud Platform has
integrated logging platform.
It allows you to
do some viewing.
It's really awesome.
But we tend to only
hang around to it
for a limited amount of time.
You can configure
it and say when
you want to drop data off and
do that sort of fun stuff.
But what happens if you want to
store your logs for all time?
Maybe you want to do some
big data analytics later on
or you just need it for
auditing purposes, or who knows?
There are so many
things you could do.
Is there an easy way to do it?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I know there is.
MARK MANDEL: There is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I've never done it.
So I'm going to let you
answer that question.
MARK MANDEL: I love this.
This got me so excited
when this came out.
If you go into the
logging section, above it,
you should see-- in the
developer console in our web
app bin, there's a
section called Logs.
You go in there.
And you'll also see
another thing called
Exports, which is super cool.
You can go in there, you
can select the service
that you want to
export, and then
you basically have a one click.
Send it to a Google
Cloud Storage bucket
if you just want to store
for a really long time
and then do stuff with it.
But you can also send it to
BigQuery and you can also send
it to-- would you
believe it?-- Pub/Sub.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Amazing.
MARK MANDEL: So if you want to
just stick it in a Google Cloud
Storage bucket and then
do something with it
later-- you don't know what
you want to do-- that's fine.
If you're really
doing analytics on it,
especially maybe
if you're doing--
say, if you've got
structured logs in JSON,
that's really powerful.
So you can send it straight
to BigQuery and stream
it straight in.
So you can do
analytics on the fly.
And then if you want to do
really crazy messaging stuff
with it, you can
send it to Pub/Sub,
which can then go to any
number of other places
from there, as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's actually--
once you have it
on Pub/Sub, you can
do whatever you want with it.
MARK MANDEL: It's crazy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You already have it.
You can create
your subscriptions
and do whatever you want.
MARK MANDEL: We actually
didn't mention it,
but Pub/Sub integrates
directly with Dataflow,
one of our big data products.
So if you wanted your logs to be
set up to go through Dataflow,
as well, that could be a really
interesting way of getting
all that data to flow through.
It could be kind of cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Which is actually--
we will be doing an episode
some time soon about all
the big data products
that we have.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
going to be covering
BigQuery, Dataflow, and so on.
And all of those integrate
amazingly well with Pub/Sub
because that's the way to go.
MARK MANDEL: That's
pretty awesome.
I don't know too much
about big data stuff,
so I'm looking forward to that.
I'm going to learn a whole lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's going to be fun.
Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
It is the end of the year.
We keep talking about it.
I believe you're just
going off to holidays.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm going to
holidays in a couple weeks.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm very excited.
And we will actually
have a break.
Will we?
MARK MANDEL: We will.
Next week should be our
last episode for the year.
And then we'll be
breaking until next year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
So what day?
We don't really know yet.
It will be a Wednesday.
MARK MANDEL: It
will be a Wednesday.
We will definitely be
back on a Wednesday.
It will be early
January at some point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, early
January, we'll be back.
MARK MANDEL: We'll
definitely be back.
Again, I will be at
DevFest in a few weeks--
the 12th and 13th of
December in Vancouver.
I am excited about a
winter in Vancouver.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay.
MARK MANDEL: Which is
going to be great fun.
And then we'll be-- I
think I'll be at home.
I'll be at home, pretty
much, I think, is my plan.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: For the break.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I won't be traveling
until the break.
I will be going for holidays
in a private location.
So that's going to
be lots of fun, too.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Anyway, lots
of fun talking about this topic
today with you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Lots of fun
talking with it with you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
see you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]